the next speaker Daniel gross is a
former YC founder and YC partner and he
is going to tell you some really
important things about staying sane and
healthy and whole while you're doing
this incredibly hard thing that is being
a start-up founder so Daniel thank you
thank you Jeff
all right hello sorry uh we're running a
little behind today it is my fault
if any of you are working on carrying
traffic I suggest you get to it a little
bit faster so this was the original
title of the talk in hindsight it's kind
of a terrible title so we're gonna
remove it this is actually what I want
to talk about today I think everyone
here fundamentally is playing a game and
you want to win that game
whatever whatever project you're working
on I'm sure people here are excited to
build kind of the next the next Empire
become the next Rockefellers and one
kind of view here that that I've noticed
over years of working with different
startup founders being a start-up
founder myself is when you're a founder
the mentality you get into is kind of
like you're an athlete and startups are
kind of the Olympics it's one of the
hardest things you can do and what I'd
like to do in this talk today is is go
over some of the kind of mistakes some
novice athletes make while they're
trying to play in the Olympics because I
do think they're kind of repeated and
over the course of the past few weeks
and I think you guys have seen great
talks on mistakes people make say when
marketing or hiring or growing your
company but there's a lot of mistakes
you make with yourself and I'd like to
help you potentially avoid them a lot of
the mistakes stem from this recurring
theme which is you're working really
hard and not smart kind of like this guy
with the rickshaw
you you don't want to be in this
position you know examples of things
that will be in your head as you start a
company especially as you start growing
out a team are you know I'm gonna be in
the office all the time or I will make
sure to be the last one out today
work as hard as I can and while there's
a lot of value in it that stuff could
kind of go wrong because ultimately
input doesn't equal output this this
founders seem to make this mistake kind
of over and over again and what they
forget is nobody wants to work for a
tired idiot it's actually incredibly
uninspiring and so you know ultimately
if we were to do a little quick Harvard
2x2 matrix here you know if you just
this is the most common startup founder
mistake where you just focus on like I'm
gonna pedal the bike as hard as possible
and you don't really get anywhere that's
kind of bad - I would not want the
outcome of this talk to be the other
extreme which is maybe like you could
define academia you get really smart but
you're not you're not pedaling as hard
what you really want us to be doing both
and so we're gonna be talking a little
bit today on on how to do that before we
dig into any details I thought it should
be interesting to maybe
quickly go over why this even happens as
a problem so out of curiosity if could
if you've ever worked for someone before
that you respected a manager you
respected please raise your hand okay
so about half of the room ultimately
when you're a founder you kind of want
to win the approval of your pack be at
your team or other founders and the
problem is a lot of first-time founders
don't really have that experience of
what that that thing you want to look up
to is so they don't have a mental model
for what to emulate and as a result
there's just like a lot of common
mistakes people make because they don't
know kind of what greatness looks like
and so they optimize for the wrong thing
all right so that should set hopefully
the the general framing for the talk
what does this actually mean in practice
so we're gonna go over a couple of
different areas common mistakes with
sleep food exercise your mind and
leadership this kind of a Maslow's
hierarchy of sorts to start up success
where I think you can only tackle the
stuff at the bottom after you tackle the
basics what's really ironic about the
advice I'm about to deliver you is I'm
sure for about half the people in this
room and I'm sure many more people on
you will make all these mistakes despite
me saying what I'm about to say it's
kind of fascinating but I'll go through
the exercise anyway just so I could tell
you I told you so
or it's asleep guys the reviews are in
sleep is the ultimate nootropic it just
takes a couple of hours to apply there
is no way that cutting that hour of
sleep was actually worth it for your
company in in unless there's a real
emergency
some people need five hours of sleep
some people don't need eight hours of
sleep some people need nine just sleep
as much as you need when I started my
first company I was very focused on as I
mentioned earlier just being in the
office all the time working as hard as
possible and again it's really stupid
and in fact bad for your shareholders
and for your entire company if you're
coming in there with 20% cognition
because you're not sleeping well I would
spend a bunch of weekend time you don't
suspend your company time on this
optimizing your sleep environment I
think sleep masks are the most
underrated product in the world in terms
of the upside that they give you in the
car this is like twenty dollars and
you'll sleep I sleep significantly
better there's a website for this that
details it I would just go through all
their products I would be incredibly
frugal in general in life and I would
spend lavishly on this one again just
think about it as a nootropic I know
there's a lot of people that are
obsessed with kind of I don't know
taking l-theanine or caffeine this is a
far better nootropic than all that stuff
so just spend on it I would try to avoid
using an alarm clock at least for half
the week again your ancestors didn't
have an alarm clock they survived you
should be able to as well sometimes you
know one thing your ancestors obviously
we're not exposed to is a lot of light
in the night and so occasionally for
setting your security and rhythm I think
for a lot of folks especially software
engineers can be helpful I think if
you're a software engineer you probably
have I found at least most software
engineers that I've worked with have
about a 25 hour cycle that is to say
they increasingly wake up later and
later and later if you take a little bit
of melatonin can actually reset that
quite well for various fascinating
regulation reasons most melatonin sold
in the United States is way much more
than you need it's like three five or
ten milligrams your body makes point
three when I wants to put you to bed so
that's what you should take
you literally have to buy this on Amazon
the reasons for which are fascinating
but outside of the context of this talk
okay so we just discussed sleep a little
bit that should be real basic I don't
think you should tackle anything else
before you're sleeping well it's again
fascinating I'm sure most of you some of
you will follow this advice a lot of
people continue doing what you're doing
but again I told you so
alright let's talk about food okay so
again just think of just think of what
you're doing and what you want your team
to be garbage food impairs your judgment
I would I at some point realized I was
letting everyone else down on my team if
I was not playing at peak performance if
I was not treating myself like an
athlete so I would not eat crap food I
really don't want to go down the rabbit
hole of like what diets to do I'm not a
dietician and I'm not here to be or Tony
Robbins but I would just focus on
whatever you think is healthy actually
think there's probably a lot of
psychological benefit to just eating
whatever you think is healthy frankly if
you believe sugar is really health if
you really believe that maybe that's
fine whatever fad you're into just go
for it this is something worth investing
in I was a contentious topic but I I
think it is immoral to have junk food
weaponized junk food in your office I
would just get rid of all of it and
focus on healthy food that's you can
find healthy foods is just just as cheap
I also think everyone is dehydrated all
the time I would try to drink an
uncomfortable amount of water this is
probably the only weird hack I'm gonna
give you in this talk most of it's gonna
be frameworks but practically speaking
yes you got it
this man is set up for success
I just I think you'll feel much better
if you do alright so that's a little bit
about food again it's I think it's
pretty simple the message here
the repeated message here is invest in
yourself because startups are one of the
most draining things you can do to your
body to your mind let's talk about
exercise okay this is probably a good
idea it's again just like sleep the
results are pretty conclusive on this
one one thing I always well taking a
step back if you don't exercise I would
at least try to spend a lot of time
outdoors if you have a team you can
start having one-on-ones outdoors if
you're managing that team if you're
somewhere terribly cold where you can't
spend time outdoors that sucks but well
maybe you should move to somewhere that
has more Sun I would always picture in
my mind because I'm an overly
competitive person that whoever my
competitor was they were probably
working out like four times a week
becoming better becoming having better
ideas becoming more creative if that
framing is helpful for you I would use
it I think you know I I don't mean to be
overly prescriptive on what you do I
think anything you do you know in the
spirit of exercise is good I don't have
to cite I can't I don't have time to
cite all the studies that correlate with
this
I do think running is probably the best
in terms of time expenditure to
potential reward if you can do it and I
think the more interesting question with
exercise is not whether you should do it
because I think it's pretty clear to
everyone on the planet you should do it
but how to convince yourself to do it
because that's that that's the harder
psychological bit the largest mistake I
think people make especially if you're a
founder of a company is you know you
have like I'm gonna go all-in mentality
you tend to go all-in two things if you
go all into something like running your
first time you're gonna hate it because
you're gonna sprint sprinting sucks so I
would I would not overdo it and I would
start really small and and build
positive memories that you can grow on
so celebrate success what you want to do
is pretty much for everything but in
this particular thing the trick is to
create a positive memory such that when
your brain predicts whether you do that
activity the next time it looks back and
thinks yeah that was it that was kind of
fun so that may mean running a mile and
then getting a Frappuccino just because
what you'll remember is getting the
Frappuccino but try to really trick
yourself into doing this it'll
definitely pay off I think the the other
thing you can do in order to kind of
reduce the willpower required to do
anything is make it surround yourself by
other people that are doing it you can
tell other people that you're running
which is great because then you'll kind
of feel like you have to do it cuz you
told everyone about it you could
surround yourself with other people that
are running for me especially through
the dark phases of my startup this this
was definitely my light it helps you
relax it helps you focus and you guys
are going to go through a lot of ups and
downs I suggest setting up these good
habits while you're either at a plateau
or at an OP because it's really hard to
convince yourself to do anything while
you're down but if you set up the mental
habit it's a little bit easier to come
back to alright so if you got down the
basics you're sleeping well you're
eating well you're exercising then we
can start to talk about kind of the more
interesting things you could you could
do and you should be doing to transform
yourself as a leader and to really take
your company to the next level
there are a bunch of kind of sub
categories within to how to think about
optimizing your mind the largest mistake
people make I think went in terms of
just thinking better is if they focus a
lot on feeding their body and then they
don't focus on feeding their brain but
ultimately your brain I think is just
constantly doing pattern recognition and
this and the pattern recognition that
it's doing is very much powered by the
information it's consumed and so you you
really want to focus on feeding your
mind like you're feeding your body what
does that mean in practice I would spend
at least one day a week not working as
hard as you can and your goal here is by
by as hard as you can you want I mean
you want to you want to do whatever
activity will help you feel the
refreshed when you come back to work and
there's all sorts of interesting studies
of spending time in nature is really
good for this may be going to the beach
whatever I don't intend to be
prescriptive but you really need to
spend a day a week not working this is
really helpful because when you come
back to work you will have like your
your brain will just be different and
it'll be solving problems in a more
novel way and let me frame it this way
your competitors are probably doing this
and they're coming up with better
answers than you are so you should
definitely take a Sabbath I mean it
blows my mind that people don't do this
the the it's it's like I guess a
separation of the the urgent and the
important that people struggle to do I
would focus a lot on reading long-form I
think a mistake people make here is
everyone talks about reading a lot and
people get very obsessed with like you
know reading is a thing to do the
greatest gift someone gave me was this
idea of not really caring about what you
read whether you even finish the book
just trying to read any book anytime all
the time like every day because I and I
think there's a common amongst founders
you get obsessed in this mindset of I
got to do it I gotta finish the book you
get stuck in a crappy book you stop
reading all together now you're on
Instagram sucks so just pick anything
continually try to read it I find that
the value that books give you are not
they're not just informational they
actually set up your mind in a
particular way like if you read a
biography about a person you'll find
yourself thinking a little bit more like
that person thought or like you read
that person thought and that afterglow I
think is really what you're trying to
get and I don't think you can get that
from short form content I would sign out
of all unless unless your businesses
tied to it in which case good luck I
would sign out of all this crap on your
phone and just make it a little bit
harder to use yeah it's just too good is
the main problem this is way too good
all right so that's in terms of how you
should feed your brain in terms of how
you should think like the software
that's running in your head probably the
largest thing you
do is you want to move from this mode
where you're playing first-person to
this mode we are playing third-person
and what do I mean by that I mean by
that it's a little bit less I'm angry
and a little bit more I'm feeling anger
the other term people use for this is
mindfulness I'm trying to avoid that and
repackage it in terms that seem a little
bit more exciting but it's building the
habit of kind of stepping out of the
frame and experiencing yourself almost
in the third-person this is really
useful because well it's actually not
that useful things go really well in
which case all of your emotions are
awesome but when things start going
south it's going to become really
important it's going to become also
really important when you start doing
bad things that are mostly a byproduct
of your own insecurities you know so
someone say who reports to you says
something disagreeable to you in a
meeting and it's quite helpful to be
able to step back and say what's
happening now is like I feel insecure as
opposed to I'm dumb which is what
actually happens if if if you're playing
in kind of first-person and you'll be
able to react better you'll be able to
lead people better in terms of how to do
it meditation is one way to achieve this
there's a lot of studies that show that
it just happens as a byproduct of being
in your mind for more years so it's just
growing up but I actually think the most
valuable way to to get better at this is
to just think about it just have the
concept in your head but it is probably
the largest most important mental shift
I think you can do as a founder because
you're putting yourself through an
emotional roller coaster so that's kind
of a large software shift that I think
is is really really important in terms
of other cheap hacks that relate to your
mind I think the simplest goal that you
should constantly be thinking about is
how to spend as much of your day and
flow as possible flows this concept of
basically becoming unaware of how time
passes there's a book written by a
gentleman whose last name I can't
pronounce so I'm not even going to
bother
mikail something about this topic that I
recommend reading
you want to spend as much of your time
and flow as possible and if you're
really good as a manager you really want
to spend your entire team's
day and flow as much as possible people
should be moving from one thing to the
next to the next to the next not even
really noticing time fly by and that is
you know it's I don't have any like
instant solutions to that but you may be
me kind of noticing a theme across the
talk here which is the key is to kind of
launch and iterate I would I would be
constantly asking yourself like what
time of day is the best for you to do
meetings what time of day is best for
the team to do meetings what music makes
you productive you know is the person
you're going to put on a particular
project are they going to enjoy that
does that match their personality maybe
yes maybe no so you need to constantly
be in this framework of trying different
things and iterating don't be on
autopilot there's a lot of information
data laying on the ground that comes out
of an omission from whatever you did by
putting a meeting super early in the
morning super late in the day bunching
meetings together keeping them separate
I don't mean to be prescriptive because
I actually don't know that that there is
a global answer but there's definitely
an individualized one to you and the the
really great people are constantly
iterating on whatever that is trying to
improve themselves so you should do that
because the competition's doing that the
last thing I want to talk about is
probably the most important one for you
as you build out a team which is how to
become a really good really inspiring
leader there's a lot of different books
on leadership there's a lot of different
studies on it most of them are garbage
there's one particularly good one that
I'd like to walk you guys through which
is Robert Keegan's theory of adult
development Robert Kagan is a
psychologist that has done a lot of work
on adult development distinct from child
development which looks like Piaget have
covered quite well it's actually not
there's there's not that much literature
on how adults say circa 18 and beyond
evolve in terms of their thinking of
thought patterns and what
done is he's kind of split out five
different phases that people tend to go
through throughout life and not all
people make it to the final two phases
the we're really going to focus here on
stage two through five since one is
basically really children I'm gonna walk
you through them and then we'll talk a
little bit about how you can kind of
advance from one phase to the next so
let's talk a little bit about an
imperial mind this you could kind of
think of this as like a very simple ai
this is someone who is for the most part
these are children but I think we all
know some adults that fit this bill this
is someone who is incredibly selfish so
they're very focused on their own goals
that's their that's the number one most
important thing for them they're
transactional so the relationship with
other people is really just a way for
them to get a thing done that they want
they're unable to the the view of the
other side is untenable to them so you
know Oh what do you think of you know
person brings up other ID I can't you
can't even get there can't even see how
that person would have that view the
challenge with this mode is that it's
really hard to get people to cooperate
with you over the long term as you guys
grow teams you may start seeing this
flaw and actually some some managers it
becomes very easy to see actually when
it's not you but through someone else
where people overtime just aren't
interested in working for them or don't
find them compelling so this is kind of
the the most embryonic phase you can be
in as an adult which i think is has
office of obvious limitations once you
advance beyond stage two you get to
stage 3 the socialized mind or as I call
it the NPC a non-playable character in
the game this is most adults and these
are people who are kind of able to see
the other side but they almost they
almost see it too well and the not sense
they're kind of NPCs they have no
internal locus of control they really
care about what other people are
thinking about them all the time and the
social narrative of you know oh people
think I'm dumb becomes their narrative
therefore I'm dumb if
make sense so you've kind of pendulum
swung a little bit too far where instead
of not carrying really about what other
people think you now are entirely driven
by it occasionally we'll see founders
that I you know are kind of in this mode
it's just it's really hard to have an
independent mindset when you're when
you're in this mode and any any any
great company as you guys know there
faces a lot of unknowns and you have to
be able to kind of stare into the abyss
and say there's a light at the end of
the tunnel and it's really hard to do
that if you're constantly gut checking
yourself about what other people think
about you there's some value here like
the opinion of other people is actually
important it's a great way to know if
you're doing something right or wrong
the problem with people in this mindset
is they're just unable to have their own
framework for how to live life or their
own kind of truly independent ideals
once you evolve beyond that you reach
the kind of master player face or the
self authoring phase and this is in
Keegan's view some adults you've less
motivation by social formation and you
have a kind of consistent independent
frame of mind and so you have certain
values certain ideals certain things you
hold yourself by and you can identify
with them and and you know what those
are you know I am a person who cares a
lot about X and that's that's like a
part of the inner monologue in your mind
importantly you're able to take
responsibility for your own emotion so
this comes back to that that point of
playing in the third person of you know
I'm feeling angry at you because you
said you you kind of assaulted a value I
hold dearly so you kind of know who you
are at this phase this is this may
actually be the best phase for a founder
because you have very clear ideals that
you hold on to you kind of know who you
are
you're aware of your emotions and in it
slightly different from that the second
phase we were talking about moments ago
you're able to kind of play an infinite
game with people where you're optimizing
for the collective group not just for
yourself but you do have kind of a sense
of where you stand there is another face
beyond it
and and kind of Keegan's interesting
claim here is that very few adults make
this phase the kind of self transforming
mind and if previously we were talking
about you know a really competent game
player this would be almost a game
designer this is someone who is not
really held by back by any sense of who
they are as a person when it values and
ideals they have and is able to
basically embrace and extend any of the
opinions and ideas of people around him
so they're constantly being recreated by
the group that they're in if that makes
sense
you could almost an engineering metaphor
would be that this person can kind of
run any idea that comes to them envy em
you know and they kind of kind of kind
of properly evaluate it they're
genuinely curious and interested in
other people they're willing to drop an
entire ideology and swap it for another
one you know in moments if it kind of
makes sense for them and unlike you know
that second phase it's not being driven
by what will other people think it's
truly being driven by the quality of
that idea and ideology the other very
interesting thing about these people
that I find fascinating is the tendency
to think in systems so when someone is
bringing up an idea you know being able
to very quickly realize oh they're
bringing up that idea because of X Y & Z
you know because that's their position
in the organization or that's their
background or that's the environment
they grew up in it's almost like you're
seeing the entire map or you're on the
hundredth floor of the building and
you're seeing the entire city fold
underneath unfold underneath you as
opposed to being on the first floor they
make the interesting case that this is I
mean this is the vision this is where
you want to get to it's actually not
clear to me for founders that you want
to be here until you have product market
fit there's something very interesting
about these people which is they're
generally I find they're very good at
managing very high quality talent who
needs to be properly heard needs to be
properly understood in order to be
inspired to come into work every day but
danger of making metaphors but when you
think of Elon or Steve Jobs it's not
clear that you end up here it's a little
bit more Stage four they have an idea
and there's going to railroad it through
but I think an but I think it's an
interesting thing to hold on to long
term and I definitely think as you guys
growing as your companies you start
building out a strong executive bench
this is actually what's required to get
a players to to be interested in working
for you you have to really be able to
set up an environment where they can
live their own ideology and they feel
challenged by you and they feel like
you're willing to adopt it and you can
actually put together people with very
different ideologies and kind of get
them to mesh together it's like you're
designing you know the game as opposed
to being an individual player so I
thought so that's so so the question is
like okay given where you know one is
and there's a case to be made that we
can't really ever evaluate where we
stand on this kind of thing how do you
move on to the next phase how do you
become less maybe self-centered and more
focused intrinsically in in kind of
motivating others to join your cause I
think knowing the concepts actually can
really help because then you can kind of
label some thoughts that you have and
say well that's you know stage two not
five and if you guys are interested in
this you should just Google Bob Keegan
and read any of his books time according
to him just kind of moves a person along
a continuum here there's of course this
question of derivative how quickly are
moving one very practical thing that I
you know I I've learned to do over the
age of the limited amount of time I've
had on this planet is when when
interacting with people especially
people that you hire I would only try to
ask questions you're genuinely
interested in hearing the answer of it's
kind of interesting especially in
interviews to hear people ask these rote
questions they don't really care about
because that's the conventional question
to ask and then they don't really listen
to the answer and then they're not
really having a good interaction with
the person so I would I would try try to
nerd Snipe yourself with this with this
idea of what would be the most
fascinating question to ask this person
now even if it's someone who is saying
something that do you drastically
disagree with it's an interesting
brainstorm of like what is something
they would say that would cause me to
change my opinion that will just make I
think life more interesting from you and
and and maybe help you kind of work work
through that continuum
so that's a little bit on leadership a
lot of this especially if this is the
first time leading a team a lot of this
is stuff that you'll just figure out as
you go along I do think it's helpful a
little bit to have these concepts in
your mind in terms of what's good and
what's bad and where you want to be okay
so I want to give you guys some closing
thoughts I think it's really important
that you that the metaphor of the
Olympics what wasn't me kidding around I
remember when I did Y Combinator in
winter 2010 James Linden mom the CEO and
founder of Oroku came by and he gave a
talk and he said a related flavor of
this which is he said that you should
bill yourself at $500 an hour which at
the time seemed insane to me until I
found out that of course that my lawyer
was billing me at 750 an hour but the
point is your time is really precious
and especially as your team grows you
will be increasingly the choke point for
getting things done and so you really
have to treat yourself as an athlete if
you want to survive this game because
there's all of the responsibilities on
your shoulders and you cannot cave you
cannot cave and and go for the urgent
instead of the important it's just not
acceptable if it's helpful I would just
assume that the others have figured this
out and they're ahead of you and you
just need to catch up to them so you
just assume that they're well-rested
they're eating properly they're thinking
properly and so when you know when you
find your I've certainly had nights when
I was running my company or I find
myself at the office three o'clock in
the morning eating skittles this is not
a good scene this idea of switching to
kind of third-party camera mode and
experiencing yourself in the third
person is really important you guys are
gonna have days months weeks where you
get punched in the face a lot like
someone it wants to quit and you lose a
customer and things aren't growing the
only way the only way to survive that
and when you're in that mode still play
all the right chess moves is to
experience your emotions in the third
person otherwise you get caught up in it
and it's just lame honestly so I spend a
lot of time thinking about that
the particulars of any hack don't really
matter I don't care if you don't
actually drink water the key thing here
is to launch and iterate your yourself
kinda you have a lot of data going on
about what's good what's bad what days
make you feel good what days make you
feel bad and just collect that
information and retrain your model over
and over and over I would very much try
to just be genuinely curious of other
people I think if you are you'll find
out other people are just the most
interesting thing on the planet far more
so than the you know VI or whatever
engineering problem you're solving it's
far more dynamic than a computer and if
you get really interested in what drives
other people what motivates them you'll
get really good at recruiting other
people you get really good at motivating
other people but you have to really
treat it as a system that you're
genuinely interested in always try to
ask compelling questions of other people
don't bore them don't bore yourself the
last thing is a concept that's a it's a
little bit hard to convey but was one of
the most helpful shifts I went through
which is you want to move from playing
very finite games in life to infinite
games and what I mean by that is 10,000
different things but I guess at a high
level you have I think when you you get
started you tend to get very worried in
various interactions that you have with
people that it's zero-sum that it's a
win-lose situation you know maybe
there's an idea you have but you're not
sure if you should share it with someone
because maybe if you give it to them
then they'll go out and run with it and
then they'll steal all the credit and
you'll be the Winklevoss and they'll be
Mark Zuckerberg or something and it's
really important to let those thoughts
go you very much want to make believe
you're playing an infinite game that
doesn't really have an end the
scoreboard is really unclear and you're
just trying to engender as much goodwill
as you want there's a great book on this
topic called finite and infinite games
that helps set this kind of mental frame
because it's very hard to explain in
words but well someone's playing Mario
but you've you want to I guess move a
little bit from from from kind of being
focused on winning one particular
interaction to winning the overall set
of interactions said differently you're
running a marathon not you know you're
not sprinting so that's it so that's a
little bit of a rant on hopefully semi
productive rant on what you need to be
doing in order to you know kind of
improve yourself in order to advance to
the next level and at the very least
should be a good overview of some
incredibly common startup mistakes
people make to the fifty percent of you
that actually follow this advice and
avoid those mistakes awesome and to the
fifty percent that don't or probably
ninety percent that don't I told you so
thank you so much you wanted sorry
Q&A yes yeah sure yeah so the question
was for people that leave kind of
comfortable corporate positions how they
handle the rollercoaster of a startup I
think yeah so occasionally you see
founders who there's basically two
reactions to this you know if you leave
you're kind of great job at Google and
you go join a startup roller coaster one
reaction is a version effectively like I
don't want to deal with that just not
focus on it or I got very used to having
you know taking an extra day off on the
weekend and so I'm just not going to
give that up
the I those companies sadly don't do
well and I think those people aren't
unhappy kind of in the process while
they're doing it you know startups are
ultimately it's like you're playing on
expert mode and it only makes sense if
you're going to commit a lot of other
people I think most founders that we've
worked with you know humans are
resilient and so you kind of figure
I think I think the the real take on it
is not whether the person got too too
comfortable it's really like are they
innately interested in working on the
problem they're working on that's what I
think is going on with a lot of those
people is they leave like Google to
start a company because they feel like
they should start a company as opposed
to like really being interested in in
making something if that makes sense
that's so that's the thing I would focus
on because if you're really interested
in something of course you'll spend all
day thinking about it sure okay so the
question is if your business kind of
demands of you to be online how do you
handle not kind of kind of falling into
the simple Maximizer trap one very funny
thing always to do in my company is we
all had our monitors facing each other
if that makes sense and so there was a
kind of a circle and there's weird
accountability that gets enforced when
you do that of course no one is actually
watching your monitor they're busy doing
their own work but in the back you have
a little voice in your head that's
saying maybe they are so that's a fun
hack that I think works quite well kind
of team enforceability the I think the
the other solution to this is is not
really tackling that problem but really
focusing on something else which is
growing as quickly as possible and if
you do like this will just be have to be
a demon you slay in the process of
growing as quickly as possible because
you cannot grow if you're watching
YouTube yeah unless you're watching your
own videos yeah cheering glass and
staring into the abyss okay so the
question is what's my mantra regarding
I don't know that I'm smart enough to
have a mantra about it
I but if probably if I were to have one
it would be something akin to it's kind
of what I mentioned earlier it's like
playing a video game on kind of expert
mode where the video game is really
managing your own psychology and trying
to build a product that works I do I do
think we shouldn't like frame this as
something that is painful I think like I
think there are a phenomenal amount of
ops that go with the Downs and for every
Elon Musk quote where he's chewing glass
and staring into the abyss he also gets
to see his roadster in space that's
pretty good so yeah so I think it's just
you I mean you have to really enjoy
building stuff ultimately yes well this
okay so the question is you know
strategies around building community and
peers in order to kind of help yourself
become better this is actually I think
one of the main benefits of startup
school and it surely one of the main
benefits of YC is that you get put in a
peer group with other people and what
happens is you very quickly figure out
humans are fascinating they they like
subconsciously almost figure out where
am I in the peer group who's next to me
who's kind of ahead of me in the
leaderboard who's beneath me where do I
stand and how can I advance myself I
think this is also one of the reasons
why I via the campuses are so good it's
not really the curriculum of the Ivy
League it's the fact that you're
suddenly surrounded by peers who are
motivating you to be better
so startup school is I think one very
interesting way of scalably trying to
give that to many people as possible on
the internet because we know that with
your when you're kind of with relative
peers you're always trying to figure out
how to improve yourself I yeah so doing
startup school is one answer to your
question to me the largest value of YC
is I was suddenly challenged by the fact
that yeah I thought other people in my
batch were really darn good and I
and I kind of realized I could compete
on the same playing field so I'd
encourage you guys to apply to IC and
also figure out what other figure out
other I don't know if there are other
like online communities where you can
kind of have that same sense of of
competing on the leaderboard okay all
the way back so the question is how do I
counter the proposed reality where
people are doing the opposite of this
presentation and achieving greatness and
I guess I would question the premise I'm
not sure I agree with you I'm pretty
sure that any successful unicorn founder
that you meet today would kind of agree
with what I said here which is even if
they were doing all this crap that I
defined is a mistake they wish they
hadn't so there's one interesting really
interesting view which is this is a
necessary pain you have to go through
you wish you hadn't but it was
worthwhile I'm not sure I buy that like
life doesn't have to suck and you don't
have to make mistakes to be successful
please it's good to know what would you
recommend doing when you're trying to
think of the next solution next product
what would you recommend the question is
what's kind of a good way of coming up
with the next product idea or pivot
you also mentioned in your question that
you were working on what one thing I
want to be clear to everyone here is I'm
not proposing you don't work hard in
order to win you have to work hard I'm
proposing you don't moronically work
hard and like not sleep because then
you're just well you're gonna have to
work much harder even to catch up but
your question was how to come up with
startup ideas okay I think the okay so
there's a lot of great content on this
topic
P G Paul Graham has probably written the
best of it I'm not gonna be able to
one-up him but I think the a common
mistake that comes to mind right now in
terms of mistakes people make when they
try to come up with the startup ideas as
they're very focused on trying to come
up with an idea in a very limited amount
of time and it's not clear to me that's
the stuff works in a pressure cooker I
think to me I've had my best ideas when
I haven't had any any kind of you know
immediate goal I have to come up with an
idea and they just start kind of coming
to you and I have a Google Doc of maybe
a thousand different ideas of which I'll
build probably none but I think the
point is it's much easier to think of
this when you're not necessarily in a
pressure cooker and I'd really question
the fact of like maybe you don't need a
start-up idea I think the most common
one of one of a very common mistake I
seen a lot of YC applicants is they're
obsessed with starting a startup which
is actually not what you want to do my
greatest hope when I have an idea today
is that someone else will build it I
have no interest in going through the
whole startup thing so if you don't have
any great ideas just that's not a
problem that's not a bug or a flaw yes
okay so the question is how do I get out
of the pressure cooker and how do I
manage risk two different questions I
think if I understand the second one
properly I think the best way to get out
of the pressure cooker is I would just
take a day a week
Saturday and just like I mentioned not
work physically like go north of if you
live in San Francisco going north of it
and walk in the woods for a while that's
great and I don't think you need that
much more than that
how do I think about managing risk
that's like a very big question um boy I
think a lot of it depends on well I
think the a very common mistake maybe
this will be somewhat novel or
interesting a common mistake people make
when managing risk is you know they
pattern match type 1 and type 2
decisions and properly that is to say
this is the Jeff business framework of
you know you got your type 1 decisions
where the cost of downside is
catastrophic type 2 decisions where you
know ultimately if you make the mistake
nothing bad happens and I think a very
common flaw is you think things are type
1 when they're in fact type to you and
and more often than not the the right
call is to just go for it or whatever
the risky path is because the downside
scenario you're imagining is a little
bit too creative probably so I've
definitely found when I've taken the
riskier approach definitely have have
been rewarded by life and I'll probably
continue seeing that until suddenly I'll
just die because I you know decided to
jump out of an airplane that was a bad
idea but so that maybe there's a
survivorship bias problem but more often
than not the riskier path is the right
one
one more question sure sorry sure yeah
so the question is how to get your
co-founders on board for doing the stuff
and again I should reimburse doing this
stuff it doesn't mean chilling
it means like not dying while you're
building your company so I think a lot
of it is the framing and I think if you
if if you're not careful with the
framing a this comes across as let's
let's bring the perks of Google into our
startup life which is a recipe for
disaster
it's hard this is a weird piece of
advice
like I mentioned three or four times a
lot of people refused to or just unable
to accept it and they need to like fail
and fall on their face before they
return the model in general though I
think this is a very interesting
question what to do in situations where
you disagree with your co-founders
especially if there's no tiebreaker a
super common problem if you like another
founder product decisions what do you do
when you disagree one useful hack I did
for a while with my co-founder because
we're great friends best friends in fact
but loose to have these bitter product
disagreements is you can just cycle
through different months where people
have responsibilities on a particular
area and so you could say look for the
next six months you're running product I
may not agree with you you get to run
product and then six months afterwards
we'll check in maybe we'll swap over but
just really defining time constrained
areas where a person gets ultimate
ownership is one I think underrated
solution to the like co-founder
disagreement problem hopefully that's
somewhat useful all right thank you all
for listening sorry we started late and
I'll be around here if you guys have any
questions I can help answer
[Applause]
you